vous avez été mal à l'aise devant les
vidéos sur johnny crying alors quitter
tout de suite cette vidéo aujourd'hui
nous allons mettre à l'épreuve notre
capacité à être ou pas mal à l'aise de
votre situation trail not to green
challenge ça devient des états unis cela
consiste à regarder des vidéos ma maison
tu as essayé de ne pas être en plein
malaise ya déjà des gens qui l'ont fait
avant moi en france les bûches peu
original je fais comme je m'en bats les
couilles c'est parti et si on n'aime pas
être mal à l'aise
affecte les noirs étaient noirs pourquoi
parce qu'il descendait de gori laisse
moi rire savez on disait aussi que les
jeunes descendent et de laurent temps et
on croyait que les bleus y descendent et
déjà penser au boulot je peux mèze
on dirait une autre une autre planète
pour cela me moquais à l'état on avance
être extasié ces voix-là avoir pris de
l'ecstasy être connaissez toutes les
deux là ah oui non mais on entend alors
en orthographe
voilà le bouquet enfin moi je n'ai pas
expérimenté patricia je ne sais pas un
petit peu non non le malaise
oui oui je parlais d'orthographe où il
fallait juste passer outre fallait pas
prochaine fois passer outre aux non à
ces dérives en plus tu peux t on pas
contre une séance urgente situation
t'as pas l'impression d'être handicap
international la lettre remise contre 1
0 qu'est ce tu veux poche tu vois pas
que ça marche pas dans ton cerveau
mais t'as juste mais lui il me
saoule la même peine mais cui
oh
j'aimerais tellement fax ap
il faut jamais jamais faire de live
quand tu n'es pas seul chez toi / règle
d'or oh non mais sinon c'est la pire des
choses quand on bat les couilles et
faire le mec assume en plus il est dans
sa rage parce que ça tu es les claques
et à ce rythme avec franchement je
compatis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a tenté de séduire un mec qui
allait un peu connu ça quelque peu ratée
ne fait jamais ça pour séduire quelqu'un
connu pas connu fait déjà mais ça c'est
sûr c'est le beh
dans l'entrepôt un but bastia qui avec
quatre suspendus du match contre ajaccio
c'est vrai j'étais handicapé par sa de
harlem cheikh diabaté cheikh diabaté
c'était un jeu de mot avec le harlem
chèque c'est bien simple à bukavu
l'avait laissé vidé à ressasser injuste
ça sachez victimes de sabena je suis
victime ça avec vous voyez des superbes
l' ue mais c'est évident et c'est pas le
droit de laisser vide est quelqu'un que
la blague et sympathique
mathis est lui bloqué que jamais vouloir
faire un tchèque et un moment d'euphorie
les vendant les tchèques mais que c'est
devenu courant
c'est même plus mal les ans et c'est la
vie
martin trouve que son hôte ne lui
raconte pas assez l'histoire est bien
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait madame va
être servi et le gars qui rentre dans le
saloon super énervé un petit cowboy qui
rentre dans le saloon il rentre dans le
coma il fait que j'ai quand j'ai pas bon
chemin en bleu il atteint les normes
gaillard qui se lève du comptoir ecully
faire c'est moi pourquoi
et puis qu'at il fait c'est juste pour
savoir quand vous allez mettre la
deuxième couche
plus la blague et rapide - en fait des
caisses plus efficace la tueuse a fait
une squeeze me fais appeler une
de squeeze et janry tombe bien
distinctes direct là haut il était utile
si la mecque
hcc merci serge lama félicitations
justement stade le plan il repart au
calme en arrière
à fermer les yeux j'avais fermeture
vérifier si la personne est là
dans une campagne présidentielle il faut
savoir se mouiller sahara et françois là
ça arrive je peux pas en vouloir
mais ce qui intéresse ça veut dire
chevaliers de la race supérieure
qu'est ce fils d'hitler mais
merde la mecque de décoder chevallier la
yemenia race supérieure arrête arrête
tout de suite il est vraiment être au
moins hilarant pousser le bouchon
pousser le bouchon
ouais
[Musique]
on va mais qu'elle avait six mois lb je
n'ai pas toucher aux impôts et produisez
fois dit on est bien aussi mais non on
va tout donner et huawei la mecque
franchement ils ont fait un projet tous
ensemble pour vanter les mérites de la
mp à 6,1 m p -o chez plus non c'est
transformé par l'image
le discours n'est pas passé en fait
c'est ça il faut juste mettre la musique
en très bonne qualité bien enregistré au
montage et faire des changements de
plans et même si c'est nul ça paraîtra
moins nul c'est ce qu'aime et vidéo
c'est que c'est de la merde mais vu que
je fais des zooms ça paraît beaucoup
moins nul à les suivants suivant et
j'espère qu'il va très ferme jusque là
je commence à transpirer mon gars
sonia voilà j'aimerais justement aval de
commencer vous poser une petite question
madame dubois
vous avez un lien de parenté avec auto
match troupes tu te rends tu vois ça ça
passe dans une de mes vidéos
y'a pas de soucis les gens sont habitués
on comprend mais dans la vraie vie il
faut le faire seulement devant tes potes
très très proches ils seront tes amis
jusqu'à la fin peu importe ce que tu
fais par exemple un jeu de mots ptc pas
de l'humour à moi ça me gave rires non
mais moi j'ose pas que ça pas l'opa
sonia revolver sinon j'aurais fait des
vannes à deux balles oh là là
aujourd'hui je pousse un coup de gueule
contre tous les cadavres de séries
policières le thème bien à la mylène
farmer
ça suffit s'est demandé c'est démonter
les gars je vous le dis il n'y a qu'une
seule série qui nous sommes c'est plus
belle la vie
là c'est les vivants qui sont maquillées
comme des cadavres on a trouvé
notre aux excuses et empire et vine
arrêt il faut absolument l'a contacté il
faut qu'on la trouvait le père s'il est
content qu'elle ait terminé et la
ville un julien allès suivant et put à
la fin s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
bonsoir matin mais attention c'est la
séquence l'habit ne fait pas le moine
j'en ai rien à secouer je suis
anarchiste et je voudrais foutent en
l'air toute la société capitaliste
tellement bader ce brouillard c'est pas
mal et ça c'est génial
un petit coucou à romane qui a vidé dont
ils regardent la télévision sur les
bonbons et qui voudraient un colis de
bonbons c'est mignon ça va s'arranger
romane c'est bien parce que vous avez
huit ans et nos côtés aux août c'est au
lycée je vais donner mon adresse
tu veux dire après tu vas du quoi je
vais donner mon adresse
j'ai bien entendu
[Musique]
drôle d'idée mais oui mais tu sais toi
qui a émis cette idée très bizarre si
vous avez vu tant vous en faites pas je
vous donnerai c'est enlever question je
n'aurais même pas de colis de bonbons
comme plus sûres
or une merde
allez courage en est presque à la fin
c'est pokémon ça doit être gênant
d'écouter ce avec son petit frère dans
sa chasse de pikachu et qu on me caresse
là comme je viens de me faire
ah oui ils adorent ça ça a l'air amusant
laisse moi et c'est s'il te plaît sacha
tu peux laisser sortir parce que j'ai
envie prendre soin des accords passeront
bientôt rejoint cdk caresser que dans la
même phrase s'affairer à n'importe quel
homme ça on est vraiment des beaufs
les amis c'est maintenant l'heure de
l'avant-dernière ces 2 0 pour l'équipe
de france et qu'on ramène euros il qu'on
reprenne salle de l'espace de l'espagnol
gars de l'équipe de l'euro 2000 à il ya
ya 16 heures il ya quatre ans et qu'on
la reprenne effectivement qu'on la
reprenne cette équipe de france dès qu
on leur amène et un but de griezmann de
giroud est allé à france à labelle ont
peut-être entendu en quoi elle est
excellent
c'est ça qui est drôle c'est que c'est
hyper sûr qu'on ne s'entend pas avec
quelqu'un qui est bègue s'il faut la
restaurer cette femme qui doit
s'exprimer c'est ce mec qui a su malgré
la surprise rester ultra sérieux au souk
quelquefois il a envie de craquer les
regards d'ailleurs d'où vient ce routier
est en jeu et ça va me regarder ça il va
craquer les premières rien d'ailleurs
hop ils verront sérieux est là il va
craquer les fabia qui regardent ailleurs
homme qu'il est sérieux il est fort les
super fort est franchement based
employés de bfm tv clara et le dernier
qui a déposé à seulement neuf minutes
si toi souviens tu étais dans l'accord
de demain tu ferais quoi
et si ma tu étais dans ce genre de
société ferait cours
je te jeter sa quéquette doit très manga
[Applaudissements]
manga et et tu vois la bouteille là
[Musique]
noir
qu'est ce que le monde devient
franchement la dernière elle marche
je vais aller me jeté par une fenêtre
les amis je revient d'entre les morts
djebbour défenestré juste une fois
gérable
voilà ça va mieux c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo sur essayer de ne pas être
mal à l'aise
est ce qu'on a réussi ce challenge
absolument pas prenez cet effet mais les
deux ça vous a plu
j'avais envie de faire ça va pour
montrer ce que c'est le vrai malaise
s'est pas johnny tagging qui joue un
rôle qu'ils jouent un aperçu de tarifs
et il est excellent acteur parce qu'on y
croit mort c'était exceptionnel c'était
ma les simulateurs
n'oublions pas que dans la moitié de ces
vidéos ça part d'une bonne intention par
exemple ceux qui font la vidéo là sur
leur classe à part d'une bonne intention
il s'est créé un truc c'est juste
cueillis s'ils prennent pas forcément
bien aux yeux et du coup ça ça ça
provoque le rire chez nous parce qu'en
vrai on est juste mal à l'aise quand je
pars du principe que même si quelqu'un
devait mal à l'aise qu'il faut pas pour
autant se moquer gratuitement de lui et
le beh et passe comment ils essaient de
créer quelque chose de faire quelque
chose de sa vie et ça c'est très bien
elle est très homogène le vert savoir
garder portez vous bien des
automobilistes
[Musique]